[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs je m'appelle
guy bois c'est moi qui remplace cette
semaine al marri yvon qui est absente et
pironi et une formation résultats pour
parler comme par le commentateur sportif
parce que charles bocquet aux personnes
est aussi absent mais on va compenser
tout ça par des invités de qualité à
commencer par viviane michel c'est la
présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec qu'elle y est tout juste d'être
réélu vous êtes là depuis 2012 je crois
évidemment j'ai terminé mon troisième
mandat sa mort c'est mon quatrième
mandat
et mon dernier mandat d'après notre
constitution a droit quatre mandats de
deux ans bon ben on reviendra vous
justement pour parler quel est votre
programme pour les prochaines années
et puis j'ai à côté de moi matthieu
servais c'est notre spécialiste du
gunner qui va nous parler cette fois du
savoir autochtone et en particulier du
savoir autochtone du côté des femmes
mais et commençons avec madame michèle
bande à michel nous on vous connaît
assez bien mais pour le bénéfice des
gens qui nous écoutent sur facebook ou
sur notre site des espaces autochtone
parlez nous de vous vous venez d'où
macarons 404 mackenzie d'apt ans je veux
saluer saluer les gens qui écoutaient
qui regardent en même temps mon prénom
et vivian michel suis de la nation innu
pour nous avait appelés les amérindiens
les aborigènes les tribus et caetera et
on s'est réapproprié notre identité en
reprenant notre identité et nous qui
veut dire être humain et vous êtes
saisis nous ici présents ou ceux qui
regardent et qui lisent sauf qu'on a une
langue et une culture différente à vous
et vous venez de malioténam sur la
côte-nord qui veut dire je pense le lieu
de marie vils instincts mari qui va
devoir donc rôles c'est vous avez
commencé en innu parce que la langue il
nous est encore très présente à
maliotenam
la langue officielle à maliotenam c'est
encore dit nous oui
la langue est encore vivante oui il est
en danger et l'importance encore de
travail et de redonner des corps
alanguis nos à l'intérieur des
communautés
oui bon madame michèle d'où vous vient
cet engagement en faveur des femmes
autochtones est ce qui est lui un
élément qui a déclenché cette vocation
je peux j'utilise le mot vocation de
manière très consciente parce qu'il faut
vraiment y croire
évidemment je pense que quelque part on
réveille un leadership sur soi même
j'étais de la catégorie de femmes qui
étaient hyper hyper enchaîné juste nommé
je tremblais ou jeter tout en sueur et
femmes autochtones du québec m'a quand
même beaucoup redonner cette confiance
ou pas outillée aussi en leadership
quant à mon implication à faire maths
horton's québec
mais est-ce qu'il ya eu un événement
dans votre vie dans votre communauté un
modèle qui vous a poussé justement à cet
engagement en faveur des femmes
autochtones actes et moi j'ai marié
j'avais marié à l'époque
un homme qui a été très très politicien
qui a été beaucoup mon mentor dans mon
cheminement jdl disait beaucoup cette
personne par sa vision de notre peuple
et j'ai beaucoup appris d'eux par louis
encore la suite très bien soutenu par
par sept personnes qui est mon ex mari
qui est là mon ami de la vie chez
l'appel de cette façon oui jusqu'au bout
cadeau de la vie soit quand même oui
évidemment oui bon est ce qu'on peut
parler mal à michel de féminisme
autochtone pardon on a de la difficulté
avec le mot féminin et
on a déjà fait un exercice lourd
d'enjeux travailler avec la maison
communautaire mesnac une maison victimes
pour les femmes victimes de violences et
on a fait d'exercer sur comment on
perçoit le mot féministe on s'est senti
comme en danger et on s'est senti en en
ressortit toutes nos craintes et on n'a
pas le don de catégoriser les choses que
l'on fait dans l'exemple la population
québécoise a le don de catégoriser les
féministes paternaliste c'est donc nous
on fait des choses on concrétise des
choses en lutte sur certains enjeux mais
c'est pour les nôtres oui et pour vous
justement vous avez employé le mot quels
sont les prix spots enjeux qui guette
les femmes autochtones gouro c'est tout
l'enjeu de là tout l'enjeu de la
sécurité je vous écoute est à la
commission on vient vous disiez ghislain
picard le chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations du québec et du
labrador a renchéri aussi vous parliez
de droit à la sécurité
évidemment les enjeux les gros en ce qui
touche nos femmes aujourd'hui sont
vraiment la discrimination systémique
le raciste systémique incluant la race
et systémique évidemment et l'impunité
qui est existante lors des gros enjeux
de violence où on a pu voir avec le cas
des femmes autochtones disparues et
assassinées
avec aussi les femmes qui ont dénoncé la
brutalité policière
ou est ce que ne sont pas protégés et
c'est ce qu'on dénonce aujourd'hui la
sécurité qui est pas donnée pour les
femmes autochtones dont on peut faire à
sortir leur assist system etc et la
discrimination existantes bon justement
vous êtes à femme autochtone vous êtes
là depuis 2012 c'est bien ça alors oui
donc c'est votre dernier mandat quels
sont vos objectifs quel est votre
programme
mon programme a été on part avec les
manteaux que les femmes nous donne
beaucoup sur la gouvernance défend
maintenant la place des femmes dans la
vie dans ces eaux dans le palier
du monde élus du monde politique et en
même temps on a aussi les deux
commissions qui vont terminer donc ça va
prendre un gros coup de pouce pour faire
réaliser des recommandations qui vont
être déposées
nous mêmes nous allons déposer des
mémoires à chacune des commissions avec
des recommandations qui va avec la
réalité des femmes et à la demande des
femmes évidemment et à la demande des
familles pour l'autre commission donc il
ya six ans je la mets aussi comment
maintenant on va travailler ensemble ça
c'est vraiment un gros défi 500
exerçaient encore les formes coloniale
il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
approchent
sauf qu'ils aient encore des formes
coloniale qui sont exercées on décide
pour nous on croit que c'est bien ce
qu'ils écrivent par rapport à nous donc
l'inclusion la consultation et la
concertation est vraiment importante
pour faire moderne du québec
oui vous avez employé le mot forme
coloniale est-ce que vous avez des
exemples concrets nous donner les formes
cologna s'est on a déjà fait affaire
avec un ministère nos dons patrimoine
canada patrimoine canada est une entité
qui exercent vraiment les formes
coloniale on doit toujours répondre à
leur façon à leurs besoins et on doit
toujours s'adapter
ça a été vraiment très déchirant de
travailler avec cette entité qui
exercent et forme coloniale et
paternaliste évidemment parce que
c'était tellement visible j'avais
tellement le goût de dire mais c'est
quoi ces formes coloniale et à
l'intérieur quand tu dépends d'un
financement qui te fait fonctionner je
te limite parfois a vraiment un talent
et les choses qui doit être dit oui
alors là vous toucher toute la question
de la dépendance économique des
organisations autochtones et voilà et on
sait que toutes les organisations
autochtones sont en mode survivance
économique même que les communautés à
l'intérieur des communautés sont aussi
en mode survivance économiques dans leur
fonctionnement
oui et quand vous rencontrez les
fonctionnaires que ce soit les
fonctionnaires à québec où les
fonctionnaires
ottawa et quand vous leur dites mais
arrêtez de nous prendre pour des enfants
arrêter cette forme de colonialisme à
l'eau on vous répond quoi
écoutez je pense que beaucoup
d'éducation à faire avec les
gouvernements
c'est de faire reconnaître qui nous
sommes et de faire reconnaître qu'à une
loi paternaliste qui était émis en 1760
détour on est en 2018
et elle est encore long on prend de la
loi sur les indiens qui discrimine
beaucoup les femmes
dans ce système et qui regardez moi ces
56 ans aujourd'hui
mais d'après la loi sur les indiens
équivaut à 17 ans ce n'est pas ce droit
de choisir ce n'est pas ce pouvoir
d'avoir une vision pour mon peuple
oui bon une vision paternaliste mais en
même temps quand on a vu le déroulement
par exemple de l' enquête nationale sur
les femmes autochtones disparues ou
assassinées
on eu très peu vu d'un autochtone
dénoncer la violence dont sont victimes
les femmes ne pourrait pas parler pour
pour les hommes se connaît la réalité
des femmes ce qu'on est le cas des
femmes autochtones disparues et
assassinées
je pourrais vous dire que dans cette
commission ce qu'on a toujours voulu et
ce qu'on a toujours aussi déploré par la
suite c'est que le côté judiciaire a été
absent ce qu'on veut prouver ou à l'état
c'est vraiment que nous femmes ne sont
pas n'ont aucune protection que les
femmes n'ont aucun aucun avancé dans le
système juridique et c'est ce qu'on
voulait prouver on voulait faire
entendre l'autre côté de la médaille et
le manque de temps évidemment a fait
qu'on n'a pas pu entendre ce côté oui
donc que vous allez être là début
décembre
mais vous avez quand même évité la
question qu'a posé la question ses côtés
les hommes en général oui il y ait des
hommes qui sont victimes de violence
tout comme les femmes merci il ya des
hommes qui deviennent agresseurs aussi
tout comme certaines femmes aussi donc
je ne pourrais pas prendre en général
l'entité désormais le cas des femmes
suprême ou l'italie de a à z
oui on va revenir justement sur vos
recommandations à même fada ça va se
passer
début décembre à ottawa entre temps je
revienne
mathis harvey qui est notre
on a list notre spécialiste du nord
cette fois ci ça va au musée intéressé
aussi le sujet madame michèle parce
qu'on va traiter de savoirs autochtones
et en particulier du savoir des femmes
autochtones
alors qu'est ce qu'on entend mathis par
savoir déjà en fait c'est quand on parle
de savoirs autochtones
en fait l'aspect critique que jacques
jambon en fait c'est ce dont ce sur quoi
le gouvernement fédéral et dans les mois
puis c'est l'inclusion de savoir
autochtone dans la recherche
scientifique pour évaluer l'impact des
changements climatiques dans l'arctique
canadien
donc en fait ce qui est difficile c'est
une bonne question quand on parle de
savoir autochtone comment définir
concrètement savoure tout ça en fait on
se rend compte que finalement il n'y a
pas une seule définition sont précises
est ce qu'on peut parler d'un savoir
autochtone de plusieurs savoir
autochtone qui est finalement dépendre
son propre à chaque communauté à chaque
famille même
donc en fait aux données au niveau du
gouvernement si on regarde la définition
qu'ils en font considère le savoir
traditionnel autochtone comme un
ensemble de croyances et de traditions
qui sont passés d'une passe d'une
génération à une autre et qui sont et
qui dans le fond sont en lien étroit
avec la nature qui dépendent du contexte
qui sont spirituels socio
environnemental et politique
mais encore là c'est cette définition je
serai curieuse justement de d'entendre
votre opinion la team à l'ats michel may
est ce que est ce qu'on peut vraiment
définir tellement ça reste un petit peu
les bulles pour vos balais michel ça
consiste à quoi le savoir autochtone et
et comment se savoir la peut aider la
science qu'on est rendu à toucher à ce
qu'on appelle l'intersection a dit est
quant à lui de publier certaines car
qu'on parle des savoirs autochtones
je vais prendre le rôle de la femme
comment on est liée à ce que la terre
nous en face que la terre nous donne
même si on est devenu moderne on est
encore lié à ce que la terre ne donne
donc pas embarquer dans le système de la
spiritualité donc embarqué dans le
système territorial
on va embarquer dans le système
identitaire dans sa forme tout un taux
de liens qu'ils ont avec la teinte et on
peut embarquer encore dans nos médecine
traditionnelle qui est encore exercer
encore aujourd'hui et l'inquiétude
justement de ce changement climatique
puis on a averti il ya plusieurs lunes
que
il ya des risques dans les changements
climatiques sauf qu'on faisait face à un
monde qui était quand même sort au monde
qu'ils étaient trop capitaliste
donc nous on voit les alizés pas qu'on
voyait encore les impacts et avec tout
ce qui entoure tout les destructeurs
justement de l'environnement ça fait
augmenter encore les risques d'avoir un
environnement sain c'est intéressant ce
que vous dites parce que finalement vous
fait le lien entre la culture et les
changements climatiques comme les
changements climatiques changent
également ou une influence déterminante
sur la culture
écoutez comment elle chance parce
qu'avec toutes les modernités maintenant
on devient aussi dépendant d'une autre
dunod de maternité on va parler des
cellulaires on va parler toute cette
technologie kino tout ce qui touche
aussi en même temps l'environnement
on sait que ces essais
désastre humain peut nuire un
environnement peu importe sur ta santé
aussi ses autres de santé mentale parce
qu'on devient très dépendants il y a
dans ce sens là pour nous évidemment ça
ne touche qu'un qu'on parle de
changements climatiques parce que vous
voyez on était dans un territoire
moi je suis de la nation innu de voix
chaque minute et nam et on était dans un
territoire où est-ce qu'on avait notre
nourriture qui est la matière première
était le caribou maintenant le caribou
est vraiment très très loin plus vers
chisasibi dans le territoire cri et on
arrive avec une une crème de
l'extinction de notre site distant
primordial et au sein de la culture d ea
nous aussi toute la nourriture des inoue
des seiyuu je pense qu'on se nourrit de
ce que la terre la terre nous a offert
peu importe les nations dans certaines
régions c'est beaucoup de l'orignal
comme les québécois maintenant et voilà
tout comme les québécois aussi
maintenant
ça c'est des impacts qui va toucher
vraiment notre identité et notre santé
vraiment parce que l'on va se nourrir de
quoi maintenant notre nourriture et les
tesselles notre nourriture n'avait aucun
produit chimique donc on est vraiment a
été radié avec ce que la terre nous ah
oui c'est un peu ce que chantait florent
vollant quand il dit tout est lié une de
ses chansons entre autres bon mathis
l'enjeu c'est justement ce sont deux
cultures finalement qui s'affrontent la
culture scientifique dit occidental à
base de rationalisme vis-à-vis de cette
culture ancestrale de cette mémoire
ancestrale directoire de se savoir en
fait qui en fait ce qu'on se rend compte
aussi c'est que dans la démarche
scientifique ont signé possibilité de
focaliser sur des angles les aspects
crise met donc ça se fait si on prend
par exemple on étudie le comportement
animal comportement des ours polaires ou
du béluga par exemple mais dans le
savoir autochtone et puis pourrait nous
dire non à michel gilles yapi eu plutôt
tendance à apprendre les apprendre les
éléments dans leur globalité donc c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de fragmenter
les choses pour les étudier de manière
très spécifiques comme le comme le fait
de manière très rationnelle la science
donc par exemple si c'est donc si on
parle de je parlais du béluga ou des
ours polaires c'est ça c'est que
finalement est ce que c'est vraiment
possible d'isoler certains aspects sont
à l'encontre de tout de tout la
globalité du milieu des traditions qui
viennent avec tout ça et par rapport à
cette problématique là où ce défi là
c'est toute la question des femmes qui
sous jacente à ça c'est que finalement
il ya plusieurs chercheurs qui considère
que qui estime qu on ne met beaucoup
trop le savoir des femmes dans
en plus dans la question dans la
question de la recherche sur wii donc
alors que l'on va beaucoup plus
privilégié quand je dis on c'est donc
d'en lâcher la communauté scientifique
on privilégie beaucoup plus les les
connaissances des hommes par exemple
détenus dans la tension la chasse dans
la pêche alors que chez les femmes aussi
à des connaissances qui peuvent très
bien contribué à la science l'exemple
qui est le plus souvent cité ces ou qui
revient beaucoup c'est la guérison par
les plantes traditionnelles qui sont
encore très importants dans toute la
connaissance de la flore du territoire
ça peut grandement influencé la science
maintenant au niveau des sciences
sociales par exemple si on prend le cas
du père l'âge donc vers l'âge de la
couture
à travers cette pratique là il ya des
fondements en arrière on passe là est
toute la question de la transmission des
traditions des dés de la culture donc au
niveau des sciences sociales ça peut
aussi être une très bonne contribution
c'est donc dire que les sciences ou
s'ils sont traversés par sas préjugés ce
que madame michèle appelle le
colonialisme est ce que vous pensez
aussi que la façon de faire parce que je
me souviens d'une discussion que j'avais
exclusive asile qui est maintenant
chercheuse et professeur à l'université
du québec en abitibi-témiscamingue a
fait justement son doctorat sur l'apport
des femmes dans la préservation du
territoire
est ce que vous voyez dans l' approche
scientifique finalement aussi poindre le
nez du colonialisme écoutez lorsqu'on
parle du territoire le lien privilégié
qui ont avec le territoire la terre-mère
comme on pourrait dire c'est vraiment
une école une école de la vie on
acquiert
des connaissances et des de l'expérience
tout en étant dans le territoire ça a
été vraiment un cousin pas que lorsqu'on
a subi le colonialisme c'est qu'on s'est
retrouvé à l'intérieur des communautés
lorsqu'on acquiert ses connaissances
c'est vraiment de naturel ce qui veut
dire je peux montrer un enfant comment
dépasser un quart temps mais on voit pas
dire l'enfant non c'est pas correct ce
que tu fais ils vont apprendre par lui à
se corriger avec toute l'expérience a
cessé d enseignement qui sont naturels
et qui sont pas punis tiff c'est
vraiment on le fait de façon avec
experte expérience et tout en exerçant
les techniques et la connaissance du
territoire la connaissance des vents la
connaissance des sortes d'arbres de
médecine
c'est vraiment une grande école
lorsqu'on parle justement de
du côté scientifique on a quand même des
craintes on ne peut pas écrire
nous on a concerté une fois désigné par
chez nous pour voir si on pouvait écrire
les médecines traditionnelles parce que
là de plus en plus on voyait que no 1 et
no no no no no jean cavé l'école les
connaissances portée de plus en plus
dans le monde des esprits la crainte
c'était qu'est ce qu'ils vont nous
léguer s'ils ne sont plus là oui et ceux
qui nous ont
ont bien dit il ne faut pas écrire les
médecins parce que c'est ma tin acier
sont écrites elles peuvent tomber sur
les mains de n'importe qui et la façon
le secret comme on peut dire le sacré ne
sera plus efficace la médecine sera pas
efficace
donc c'est des choses qu'on ne peut pas
toucher si on devient quelqu'un qui va
faire de la médecine c'est une médecine
qui vont aller vers la personne qui est
désigné pour voir faire ce genre de
médecine
oui mais ça pose toute la question de la
transmission de la tradition aussi et
voilà
mais il ya quand même une façon de
continuer à faire la transmission a
justement profiter de l'existence de nos
aînés et de la génération qui ont suivi
déterminé parce que de plus en plus
épars mais c'est tout beaucoup au niveau
ce que les femmes nous nous ont dit
qu'on aura eu comme mandat de travailler
la gouvernance traditionnel jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la
transmission de la langue la
transmission de la culture parce que de
plus en plus les jeunes sont en crise
identitaire
ce qui amène justement des des
problématiques à l'intérieur des
communautés on va parler de consommation
etc
les valeurs changent donc on doit
retransmettre les valeurs de respect et
continuer à exercer notre identité avec
fierté
oui justement mathis pendant qu'on se
parent se déroule en abitibi
actuellement un colloque justement sur
le savoir autochtone qu'est-ce que de
quoi on parle je souhaitais je sais pas
si vous avez suivi un peu c'est un peu
plus au sud de la région contre est un
regard sur l'article mais c'est tout à
fait pertinents ces tests organisés hier
et aujourd'hui à la merci du québec en
abitibi témiscamingue le campus de val
d'or puis on abordait toute la question
des
les collaborations entre autochtones et
non autochtones dans la science donc
tout là toute la question du nombre de
chercheurs autochtone et
d'universitaires autochtone qui sont de
plus en plus présents aussi donc
justement vous parlez de suisse basé
l'aller elle est présente depuis hier à
7 assez similaire oui justement suzy
basim qui me disait moment donné il
faudrait peut-être arrêter de faire des
recherches sur les autochtones et on
pourrait faire des recherches avec les
autochtones
ouais voilà l'inclusion et est vraiment
importante je pense que c'est c'est ce
que le peuple québécois oublie parfois
lorsqu'il veut collaborer avec les
premières nations c'est vraiment
l'inclusion le droit de regard la
concertation la consultation ça c'est
vraiment des des points très importants
pour avoir un travail efficace dans
l'est dans les deux sens oui alors
maintenant oui les choses dont on parle
et on parle des défis que du côté de la
recherche scientifique et de savoir ça
s'est quand même fait il ya quand même
des dégâts quand même des exercices est
pas incompatible
ça s'est fait au nunavut en fait dans la
loi je sais pas si vous avez la loi sur
la faune et la flore du nunavut où on a
été gré des eaux politiques publiques à
cette loi là on a intégré le savoir des
silhouettes justement et on doit le
prendre un peu plus le prendre le
respect des délais des animaux à travers
la chasse le respect des autres donc on
intègre un accès beaucoup plus sur le
rapport des gens avec la nature donc
quand même possibilité d'orienter les
politiques publiques en fonction du
savoir traditionnel et puis de l'apport
des peuples autochtones
madame michèle j'aimerais vous parler de
l' enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones se signer ou disparus en ce
qu'on appelle dans notre langage
l'une fada vous avez été très très très
critique face à cette enquête critique
en terme de expliqué tout à l'heure que
femmes autochtones du québec depuis le
début a demandé une commission denquête
juridiques judiciaires plutôt pour faire
ressortir justement les services
marquant aux femmes autochtones ou aux
familles qui font des signalements donc
on sait par justement avec l'émission
les émissions enquête qu'on a vu que
lorsqu'il s'agit des femmes autochtones
disparues assassinées et cancon le nom
un signalement lido s'y sont mis à part
où il n'y a pas d'avancée dans le
système juridique et si ce qu'on voulait
montrer noué avec le manque de temps
évidemment deux ans est très court pour
une enquête nationale qui touche tout le
canada c'était comme un sens c'est
d'avoir sur deux ans pour une commission
des requêtes
évidemment la commission nous ont quand
même approché pour sa demande de délai
mais déjà au départ nos quand la
commission été mis sur pied les communes
et les organisations autochtones a été
consulté par la commission et on avait
déjà enfin la commission de demander des
gens un délai dans les débuts de ces
travaux parce qu'on disait que deux ans
c'est trop court ce serait le temps et
on était prêt à appuyer la demande de
délai la demande de délai a été déposé
six mois avant la fin de leur mandat
on aurait pu déjà devancé il ya
longtemps bon jeu quand même je félicite
la commission lyon fait du mieux qu'ils
ont pu avec la commission là où est-ce
que j'ai été critique c'est vraiment le
côté judiciaire manquantes dans la
commission denquête on dit que c'est une
commission denquête donc enquête aurait
dû se faire pendant cette commission est
faire entendre justement l'autre côté de
la médaille qui est les enquêteurs on
aurait pu faire entendre des enquêteurs
on aurait pu faire entendre
le système judiciaire qu'est ce qui se
passe quand il ya un signalement de
disparition de ferme autochtone ça me
donnait un peu plus dedans
cette commission dans laquelle
finalement et voilà et après on aurait
pu justement s'appuyer indices en bon
garder au gouvernement regarder ce qui
se pensent nos femmes autochtones ne
sont pas protégés on a besoin de
protection si un policier ne venez pas
capable d'appliquer son code d'éthique
ou son code de déontologie mais je pense
qu'il ya des mesures qui devraient se
faire si ce code n'est pas respectée
donc toute personne qui a besoin de
protection et de sécurité
peu importe son origine 100 grâce au
sens ethnique
je pense qu'on a besoin de protection et
nos soeurs nos vies nos femmes ont
besoin de cette protection
oui c'est un peu le voyage que vous
aviez livré également à la commission
vié qu'est ce que vous attendez
finalement de ces deux commissions là
parce que bon pour les fadas il y aura
vos recommandations que vous avez et
livrés début décembre et par la suite
aussi la commission vient s'allier à
échéance justement alors quelles seront
vos recommandations qu'est ce que vous
attendez du rapport comme est petit
c'est sûr qu'on a entendu de plusieurs
pour ce qui est de la commission
provinciale
moi je vois tout j'ai toujours que tu as
claude je vois de loin je vois ce qui se
passe à l'arrière scène et quand qu'on a
mis la commission provinciale
en mars mais on a cité d'autres d'autres
thématiques qui sont vraiment
importantes aussi oui le racisme qui
existe envers des services publics et on
a ajouté la protection de la jeunesse
qui sont de très gros enjeu et d'après
les stratégies justement du palais
gouvernemental on rajoute deux autres
pour qu'on puisse atténuer d'où part
cette commission il faut pas oublier
qu'il ya des femmes qui ont eu le
courage de dénoncer la brutalité
policière
et ce sont des choses qui sont vraiment
inacceptable
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu aller
témoigner à la commission vient pour
revenir au point de départ
et ne pas oublier qui s'est passé
quelque chose et qu'on doit que le
gouvernement doit rétablir son système
judiciaire évidemment on parle de la
sûreté du québec étaient donc des choses
qui doit être fait non aux besoins de
protection nous femmes ont besoin de
protection
on ne veut pas laisser une porte ouverte
à une violence gratuite où nous les
femmes les femmes autochtones
on serait les meilleures cibles pour ces
prédateurs ou ses assassins bon je pense
que votre message est très clair mais
très souvent quand on parle des femmes
autochtones on parle de femmes comme
victime et avec raison c'est pour ça
qu'on a une enquête sur le plan fédéral
c'est pour ça aussi que la commission
vient parce que l'élément déclencheur ça
a été ce reportage de radio canada sur
la relation entre les les policiers de
la sûreté du québec et les femmes
autochtones dans la région de val-d'or
cela dit est ce que ça ne masque pas le
fait que les femmes autochtones prennent
de plus en plus de place sur tous les
plans dans les communautés sur le plan
politique sur le plan d'éducation sur le
plan de la santé
mais je ne dirai pas non parce qu'ils
écoutent et ce parce que c'est un moment
très important
iliad et de l'injustice qui se fait sous
le doux des femmes autochtones et on
locke et on le crie haut et fort pendant
combien de temps qu'on a dit que le
l'anc est que les femmes autochtones
disparues assassinées et est un enjeu
important est que le gouvernement s'est
même pas lever le doigt pour faire
quelque chose pendant au moins 13 ans
qu'on était dehors à se geler les pieds
il pleuvait
il faisait froid on était là pour encore
revendiquer une commission denquête et
j'ai quand même une bonne reconnaissance
envers le peuple québécois parce qu'il y
avait le peuple québécois
c'est c'est nous ont soutenus dans cette
démarche
et quand le peuple québécois ne soutient
le gouvernement fait un peu plus
attention parce que l'on maintenant il
ya ses propres citoyens qui qui viennent
crier haut et fort kent injustice qui
est fait pour les femmes autochtones
donc je pense que on est rendus dans ça
fait longtemps que ces femmes là on va
parler bientôt de la loi sur les indiens
qui discrimine une loi qui est des 6700
santé pour qui discrimine encore les
femmes savez-vous que sur la loi sur les
indiens
on nous les femmes autochtones on nous
impose la reconnaissance de paternité et
s'il n'ya pas de reconnaissance de
paternité des noms automatiquement on
dit que cet enfant là est né d'un père
québécois vous voyez encore les formes
d'intimidation éléphants de
discrimination systémique et existantes
envers nous donc c'est ce qu'on dénonce
on dénonce depuis bien bien longtemps ça
fait pas depuis 2015 bien avant ce qu'on
dénonce qu' il ya des inégalités ou de
l'injustice qui s'affaisse ou le dos des
femmes autochtones
bon je pense que si un consensus qui
existe et même je l' ai entendu de la
bouche
justin trudeau c'est que la loi sur les
indiens est une loi colonialiste c'est
une loi qui n'a plus sa raison d'être
donc là dessus les autochtones et
qu'ottawa 100 ans et on va attendre
évidemment la voir la position du
gouvernement de la cac là dessus et tout
le monde semble s'entendre sur la
meilleure façon finalement c'est de
faire en sorte que les nations
autochtones puissent se gouverner elle
même et ça veut dire quoi pour vous
l'autonomie gouvernementale
ecti toujours de tommy l'autonomie
gouvernementale en or l'autonomie
gouvernementale lorsqu'on sera en aura
une
une force économique mettant où est ce
qu'on va être capable de couper les les
camps de ceux qui nous gouvernent ce qui
veut dire cette dépendance envers les
gouvernements et par la suite retrouvé
nos valeurs est vraiment important parce
que le gouvernement quand même réussi
lorsqu'on dit qu'ils visaient pour mieux
régner et on je peux le voir un peu
partout que cette application elle a été
quand même réussi dans un certain sens
comment on va être capables de
travailler ensemble
il faut avoir une vision à long terme
qu'est-ce qu'on veut léguer à nos sept
générations futures ça c'est vraiment
important c'est ce qui est dans la
tradition ils nous font toujours pencher
sur génération ouvrir la voie là faut
toujours penser à long terme avoir une
vision avoir des démarches maintenant
plutôt qu'en contemporaine mais tout en
ajoutant des priorités ce qui veut dire
en ajoutant à retrouver notre identité
qui veut dire la langue la culture et
notre lien avec le territoire l'accès au
territoire et ses terrasses devraient
être des priorités pour ma part belle à
michel en terminant sûrement que des
auditeurs des gens qui nous regardent
aussi qui se demande qu'est ce que veut
dire cette belle plume que vous avez
goût écoutez c'est pas une plume c'est
une aile ailes de l'aigle
je suis très très spirituel je travaille
avec mes outils pour travailler avec un
micro et une caméra ben moi je travaille
avec avec mon oeil d'aigle qui m'aide à
me soutenir dans tout tout le travail
que j'ai fait merci beaucoup mais là
michel d'avoir été là je connais votre
emploi du temps je sais qu'il est très
chargé merci beaucoup
jamais cia mais merci beaucoup 26 pour
cette chronique et puis pour nos
auditeurs les gens qui nous regardent
la semaine prochaine vous allez
retrouver avec plaisir à deux mains
libres au revoir bonne semaine
et une d'amiens
[Musique]